el final de esta guerra puede no estar a
la vista pero volodymyr de lenski quiso
agradecer a estas tropas ucranianas su
servicio hasta ahora en un intento de
elevar la moral el presidente ucraniano
visitó las posiciones del frente en el
donbass
estoy orgulloso de todas las personas
que encontré con las que estreche la
mano con las que me he comunicado y a
las que he apoyado hemos aportado algo a
los militares
también les trajimos algo de ellos
aportamos confianza y fuerza son buenos
deseos que la gente del issys suns que
necesita desesperadamente la casa de
oleksandr acaba de recibir un bombardeo
ruso dijo que solo tuvo el tiempo para
salvar a su de atún aquí disparan sin
parar no sé de dónde disparan quién
dispara como vuela es un espectáculo de
horror el vecino del isi sans
severodonezk también está soportando el
peso de la ausencia rusa mientras moscú
lucha por derribar la que es la última
ciudad controlada por ucrania él wons
que las autoridades ucranianas afirman
que los militares ucranianos siguen
repeliendo los ataques en donde esquivan
las dos zonas conforman el donbass una
región en la que el ejército ruso ha
centrado su energía y potencia de fuego
en la captura